think that sometimes when you're on a
reality show um your context is only
where you are and and and what you see
and what you hear as opposed to when it
airs you know you don't know what
somebody else said in their uh in their
interview or how they took your date or
how they did that and then you see that
and that could impact you and there's
nobody sitting beside you at home to go
I came off like a [__] idiot totally
or or maybe you didn't or were made to
look like you came off like an idiot
right and there's nobody and and
therefore when I heard about this
Foundation or whatever it is is it a
foundation is it a what is it a group I
think it's a charity UK can that focuses
on um working conditions for reality TV
personalities and also therapy for those
people which I thought was a great
idea if you don't think so you don't
think so well again I just don't think
um it was presented in an accurate way
again like again the the focus was on
the working conditions I think no one
care I think no one's going to take care
of your mental health more than you're
going to so I think we have to you know
be accountable for our mental health
first and
foremost um and again I think most of
the struggle that people have from a
reality TV space that you when it comes
to mental health again is the aftermath
it's it's not you know not to get into
some some of the things that they said
but it's not necessarily you know the
long days that are you know the
production schedule of of some of these
the shows that you know there's just a
lot going on but it's it's the Reddit
post in the comments on Instagram and
the reading the articles about yourself
and these same people who were
complaining about that are the same
people who are also you know promoting
internet bullying and trolling other
people because they disagree with and
it's just like to me they there's a bit
of a hypocrisy in that there is and I I
just think again I I huge advocate for
therapy and taking care of your mental
health but I'm also advocate of pleasing
yourself post show and getting the the
help that you need and and and reaching
out and asking for help when you need
it's not necessarily go you know asking
fans for donations because you don't
like how things played out when you were
filming something and again if you're
going to complain about that I would
like to see people take you know actions
when it comes to how they handle
themselves and how they protect their
own mental health postow which which
comes down to your time on social media
and your willingness or lack thereof to
Google yourself or to you know immerse
yourself in the comments and redit posts
and because that can really destroy your
mental health you're you're you're
chasing validation and you start editing
yourself and or you respond to things
like a a a a big thing that happens in
our world you know as a podcaster for
example ex Le um we recap other shows
and a pretty common we're right now
charity the current Bach Chet's going on
overall I love charity I think she's an
entertaining bat sherette really been
enjoying her I'm surprised by how much
I'm enjoying her because she comes from
a therapy background so I thought she
might be more reserved you know I
thought she might be more guarded which
you know as a in life probably a good
thing to be on TV it's not as
entertaining to watch right so but I I
found her to be entertaining I've also
noticed that she seems to be attracted
to you know pretty men and she seems to
be a magnet for [__] boys and so uh
that's just my opinion right and so I'll
say this on a an episode one episode My
overall sentiment is love Charity's bash
Rett really entertained by her but
someone who might be a fan of Charity
almost I guarantee this has happened
without confirming because it happens
every season they will take a critical
comment that I might say they will DM or
message Charity saying can you believe
what Nick V said about you blah blah
blah blah blah most people will then
like read that headline get man get
furious maybe you know and they'll
cherry-pick the CR you know and so again
it's like stay out of your DM stay out
of your comment these there's things you
can do you know seek advice from people
who been been on these shows and and get
you know feedback on how to protect your
mental health uh you know that's this
been my experience because that's your
experience but my experience as an older
guy and who's lived a lot of life I
don't think people have that kind of
self-control or awareness I think we're
saying the same thing I don't we're
disag I think it started with my
misunderstanding of what you were
against you know I did like U I do think
that there should be something set up
for reality stars where they have and
not necessarily by the actual production
company but just an overall place where
they can go because nobody can explain
to you how are reality stars part
they're not part of a union right I
don't think so no no not based off their
time as reality stars right they can
become actresses and actors and and and
join a union but I I don't think that's
what they want um the uh yeah but the
particular thing you guys are referring
to I I just didn't agree with how it was
delivered or how they went about it I
again and I don't agree that um I don't
think it's okay to ask for fans and kind
of plate to your fans and they are fans
of you um and I don't think they should
be responsible for paying for you know
your your
therapy